exactly one week from today we'll
celebrate our nation's 244th birthday
over all those years we face major
challenges but seldom so many all at
once the pandemic the subsequent
economic crisis and now a civil-rights
reckoning are not only making headlines
they're rattling many of us to the core
now some are looking to help us address
that stress with mental health tools
tailored to those who are most affected
the fever came with the breathing
combined and I didn't know if I was
gonna be able to take my next breath
neonatal ICU nurse Tanya Cornejo has
been on a long road to recovery from
Kovan 19 I was so busy worried about
myself my health my worried about my
children and their safety my husband and
his safety
I really wasn't focusing on my mental
health and the mist of the pandemic you
were at your wits end of course yeah I
needed that time to focus and check in
with myself and say this is where I am I
am in crisis I am afraid and I need to
accept that and work through it
[Music]
for those five minutes of mindfulness
Cornejo turns to shine a self-care app
that offered free subscriptions to
essential workers frontline workers
aren't the only ones needing support
recent data from the Census Bureau
suggests one third of Americans are
showing signs of clinical anxiety or
depression a figure that is not
surprising to psychiatrists marquita
wills the public user communities of
color were already dealing with the
stress of being hit harder by kovat 19
but after George Floyd's killing the
disparity became more stark with more
than 40% of black Americans screening
positive for anxiety or depression
historic transgenerational traumas that
we will face as a unique expression
right now have you found through your
experience that mental health is used
against changing moral idea Naomi
haribhai ah she are intent on creating
one of those spaces
they were the founders at shine the app
nurse Tonya Cornejo and more than 4
million others used to decompress we
name name and experience or a feeling
that connects to being marginalized
because it helps give us the vocabulary
of oh that's what it was right that's
what I was feeling and I didn't know it
was called that I didn't know other
people were experiencing that are more
people reaching out are they finding you
in this time of crisis whether it's
covin 19 or it's the protesting movement
that has been sparked by the death of
George Foley
what we're finding is those users are
looking for a deeper level of support
around racial trauma and we're also
seeing an influx of new users who didn't
realize that shine was founded by a
black woman or two women of color many
of you could be struggling with what's
called compassion fatigue this is a type
of burnout faced by health care workers
and caregivers in addition to free
resources for essential workers shines
meditation specific to black well-being
have been in demand racial trauma is the
mental health symptoms a person
experiences as a result of racism or
discrimination I think what's so
important is that we have a daily
product and daily content that speaks to
the experience of being marginalized
whether that's an Asian American being
experiencing racism due to Kovan 19
black Americans are dying at higher
rates and dealing with a structural
racism that's finally being confronted
in our country we're talking about that
every day hey shine family I'm jameelah
90% of shines content is voiced by black
women designed to connect with
underserved communities we hope that
shine as a coalition of mental health
organizations around the world
fundamentally shift representation and
access in mental health care and that we
see those direct results in anxiety and
depression specifically for marginalized
communities
welcome to daily shine and everyday help
people like Tanya Cornejo not only cope
but thrive that helps me to focus and
say yeah I do need to check in with
myself
I need to make sure that I'm coping well
so that I can get through this and be
here for my family and not just be here
but being present and you know in
talking to Tanya so hard for us to wrap
our heads around the fact that these
apps there's so many of them out there
can really help you in five to ten
minutes just breathing just breathing I
can make all the difference so important
and it's important to find the right one
and then what I think what was so
important about the piece Michelle is
pointing out that it is different the
experience is different for every single
person and that race can play a factor